too many of us confuse that the
short-term impacts that we're having are
producing long-term value or conversely
having no short-term impact means we're
having no value so for example you can't
go to the gym for nine hours and get
into shape it literally doesn't work no
matter how much effort you put in but if
you work out every single day for 20
minutes guaranteed 100 you will get into
shape when will you get into shape no
clue over time and everyone's different
some people a little quicker some people
a little slower and yet we are a hundred
percent sure it'll 100 work
just don't know when and we're also
obsessed with predicting when it has to
be this quarter it has to be the end of
the year it has to be when we pay taxes
and I got very comfortable saying I know
that if I stick to the process I know
100 it's going to work and I have to get
comfortable that I have no control over
when and so the things that I wrote
about and start with one is the game
plan that I have followed since I first
wrote about it